okay we have all the jurors
michelle horn ready to proceed
all right this is state versus michael
albariston indictment
19-12-0-9-9-9-i may have appearances of
counsel
hey please report christopher sheldon to
the state good morning your honor
alexander ben on behalf of the states
all right good morning everyone please
be seated hope everyone had a nice
weekend
record will reflect mr barristone as
present dressed in street attire
including a shirt and tie
all right if we're ready to proceed
let's call the jurors in please
who's your witness mr shalhorn detective
jason
and you'll have another witness after
that yes detectives
um
so
good morning everyone please be seated
hope everyone had a nice weekend
we are ready to proceed with the state's
case mr shellhorn good morning please
call your next witness
thank your honor the state calls
detective jason gould
all right detective jason gould to the
stand
[Music]
morning detective can you please place
your left hand on the bible raise your
right hand listen to the oath as my
court clerk administers it please do you
swear in the presence of almighty god
that the testimony goes to this court
regarding this matter shall be the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth yes please state your name and
spell your last name for the record
jason gould
g-o-u-l-d thank you
a good detective please have a seat keep
your voice up nice and loud so all the
members of the jury including those in
the gallery can hear if you don't
understand a question please indicate
that i'll have council rephrase okay go
ahead mr shelton thank you
good morning detective good morning can
you please introduce yourself again to
the jury and tell them where you work
sure my name is jason gould i'm a
detective at the morris county
prosecutor's office
what is your current rank and assignment
i'm a detective i'm assigned to the
specialized crimes division have you
ever been assigned to any other units
with the prosecutor's office yes what
units the major crimes unit and general
investigations unit do you have any
prior law enforcement experience before
you joined the prosecutor's office yes i
do i was a police officer in randolph
the randolph police department for
approximately 11 years
i want to take your attention to august
7th of 2019 were you working for the
prosecutor's office at that time yes sir
what unit were you assigned to at that
time the major crimes unit can you
briefly explain to the jury what the
responsibilities generally are of the
major crime scene
yes we respond to
or investigate death investigations
homicide shootings suspicious death
suicide
drug-induced deaths fatal
motor vehicle crashes
bank robberies aggravated assaults
at the time you were assigned to the
major crimes unit in august of 2019 what
was the typical dress or uniform
uh similar to how i'm dressed today
suit and tie
how does the major crimes unit from the
prosecutor's office typically become
involved in an investigation generally
we are notified by a local municipality
and or the state police
through the morris county communications
center if they're looking to speak with
an alcohol detective of the unit
now specifically on august 7 2019 at
approximately 2 25 that afternoon do you
remember where you were
yes i was in the uh major crimes
um squadron at the morris county
prosecutor's office who was the
supervisor of the unit at the time uh
sergeant michael poskus
at approximately that time on that day
did you become made aware of uh an
incident in washington township yes
can you very very basically describe
your understanding of the nature of the
incident we were advised that there was
an active shooter and there was one
person who received
two gunshot wounds
at some point were you given a an
assignment respective to that
investigation yes sir what were you
assigned to do
i was asked to respond to the morristown
medical center
do you know if any other members of the
major crimes unit were given different
responsibilities yes they were who made
that decision sergeant michael poskus
are you aware of what other agencies
were involved in the investigation yes
the washington township police
department
and
the morris county sheriff's office
at some point did you respond to the
morristown medical center yes sir do you
recall approximately what time you
arrived there i arrived at approximately
3 40 p.m
when you arrived where did you go
uh to the icu intensive care unit
were there any other law enforcement
officers related to this investigation
at the hospital at that time
yes sir there was
sergeant
burns of the washington township police
department
and
detective kovacs from the morris county
sheriff's office crime scene
investigations and you recall generally
how they were dressed
uh they were both in uniform
are you aware when you arrive whether
any individuals were already at the
hospital
yes
upon arrival i was advised that the
victim of the shooting
lauren karenick was
in intensive care
approximately how long were you at the
hospital overall on august 7 2019
approximately six
hours now at some point did any other
individual involved in this incident
arrive at the hospital yes who was that
uh michael marisol
and do you see michael barrasson in
court today yes i do could you identify
that person by an article of clothing
away yes he's seated at the table
wearing a white shirt
a yellow tie has
glasses on and
long
gray hair
a stipulate he's identified my client
yes he has identifying the defendant
michael barissone for the record are you
aware of how the defendant arrived to
the hospital
yes he was transported from
the scene in an ambulance
and do you know approximately what time
he arrived at the hospital
um he arrived at approximately
um
3 40
pm from what i
recall
do you recall if there were any law
enforcement officers with him
yes
do you remember who that was yeah so
there was patrolman barnes
and patrolman hensley
of the washington township police
department do you recall how they were
dressed
in full uniform
do you know where the defendant was
taken in the hospital he was also taken
i see you
was the area where the defendant was
taken nearby where
lauren canara was yes it was can you
describe that to the jury yes mr
barriston was taken to a room uh
directly um next to the room where mrs
karanick was
and where were you posted
in the hallway
what was your purpose in being there
just to get uh updates on both patients
to be able to relay back to
my chain of command
was the area where the defendant was
being treated open or closed
uh
closed
was it closed with a door or something
else uh more or less a curtain
were you able to see the defendant in
the room at all yes can you describe his
appearance for the jury
yes he came in wearing
no shirt
and a pair of
shorts
he had visible injury
to his
to his face
to his left arm
left abdomen
and where was he in the room
he was in a hospital bed
was he restrained or handcuffed at all
in the room yes he was which was it
uh he was handcuffed
were medical personnel in the room at
all yes and did you observe generally
what they were doing yes what was that
uh initially just assessing him for his
injuries
um and then subsequently treating him
for his injuries
during the time that the defendant was
in the room did you overhear him make
any statements yes i did
did you overhear the statements or do
you recall the statements verbatim or
generally what the the nature of the
statements were in general nature
can you tell the jury what the
statements that you overheard him making
in a general sense were yes i heard him
make two statements one to the effect of
they destroyed my life in the last six
months
followed
approximately one minute later by i had
a good life
they took it all away i'm sorry it
happened
do you recall how many times uh the
approximate number of times that he said
each statement once
did you record those statements in any
way
yes i noted them on my field notes
did you later add that into your formal
police report yes sir
how far would you estimate that you were
from the defendant at the time you
overheard those statements
approximately 10 to 15 feet
did he make those statements in response
to any questioning by you no sir did he
make them in response to questioning by
other law enforcement officers no sir
did he make him in response to any
medical personnel no sir
what was his appearance or demeanor
during the time you observed him making
mistakes
uh he was cooperative uh was expressing
verbally that he was in pain
did you have any issues understanding
the words or language that he used
are you aware during the time that he
was being treated by medical personnel
of whether they were administering any
medications to him
prior to the hospital i can't i can't
say that
at the time that you were observing him
getting treated in the room at the
hospital yes he was given medications
for pain
do you have any direct knowledge of what
was administered
yes just prior to making the initial
statement which i just testified to he
was given a dose of fentanyl
do you know that because you saw that or
i how do you know i observe that and
then ask subsequently ask the hospital
staff
and then after he was also
continuing to
verbally express that he was still in
pain
and he was given subsequent
doses of what i was advised was fentanyl
and ketamine
so you don't know that that was what was
administered that's just what you were
told yes
were you present when the defendant was
photographed and processed by csi
detectives yes i was
you recall approximately what time that
was it was approximately 9 pm
did the csi detectives take possession
of any items that came to the hospital
with the defendant yes and did they do
that while you were still in the
vicinity or the area yes
do you recall in general what those
items were
just from right they just dug clothing
just may have permission to approach
yes
just for the record i'm going to show
the detective what's been marked as s193
detective gould i think there are some
gloves there
if you need them
but if you could just open that bag
and look inside and
indicate whether or not that appears to
be
some of the items that were recovered at
the time you were at the hospital
yes
any objections
193 will be admitted into evidence
detective you could just remove that
item and show it to the jury and tell
the jury what it is and show it to the
jury
part of a
waste felt
another uh
it's the other part of the belt
and then khaki
i guess torn khaki
pants
and are you aware of whether those were
cut in your presence or
outside your presence outside
anything else you can just ask the jury
in the back if they need the detective
to
hold those up again members of the jury
were you able to see the close
i see everyone nodding their head yes
thank you
[Music]
so
detective you indicated that you were at
the hospital for approximately six hours
yes sir
when you left the hospital where did you
go
uh i left the morristown medical center
and responded to the scene of the
incident
and was at a 411 west 411 west mill road
in washington
morris county when you got there did you
have any assignment at that location
yes sergeant puskas requested that i
assist detective corporal mangia frida
of the morris county sheriff's office
crime scene investigations
to conduct a search
of a vehicle at the scene
do you recall what type of vehicle that
was this was a
silver and color dodge ram pickup uh
four door do you recall approximately
where that was parked
near the
residence that the victim was residing
in
judge no further questions thank you
cross-examination
detective
you previously testified in the hearing
regards to
this case correct yes sir
and were you given a transcript of that
previous hearing uh prior to your
testimony today yes sir
and you refused that with the prosecutor
correct
yes sir
isn't it the fact that in that prior
hearing
you testified that the fentanyl was
given after the statements correct
initially yes
and then
and correct me if i'm wrong when i
brought out your notes
it's clear from your notes
that the fentanyl was administered prior
to any statements correct a dose of
fentanyl was
given prior to the initial statement yes
and when you say a dose
a hundred
milligrams of fentanyl was injected into
michael barrasson prior to any
statements correct
yes sir
now
you've been
in law enforcement for how many years
total
in january i began 16 sir and
would you agree with me that it's
important
when
drafting an official
drafting a official report
concerning an incident
that it has to be accurate
and contain
as much detail as possible
yes sir
now
when
you got to the hospital
uh there were already numerous other
officers correct
there there was law enforcement there
yes
and was
were people talking about
this case and what had happened back at
michael barristone's farm
yes that was
something that was spoken about
now michael barrasson was taken into a
room uh you you've been shown the pants
which have been admitted into evidence
was he wearing any shirt
not that i recall
now
those pants that you
show to the jury
are there any holes
in the groin area
between michael barrasson's where
michael barrasson's legs would uh
be
i would have to inspect them again sir
can you do that yes
[Music]
so
there are two tears in the pants that i
see
and close to the groin would those two
tears be approximately where my hand is
on my leg approximately sir
and for the record i'm
pointing to the upper groin area
now
indicated on direct when you saw michael
barristone that
you observed numerous injuries correct
yes sir
um
for instance you observed his uh
his left arm correct yes sir
and would you describe it as uh deformed
yes sir
incapable of holding an item at that
point based on your observations correct
i couldn't say definitively sir but yes
he had an injury to his left arm a
severe injury based on your observations
correct
significant yes
now he also had injuries to his face
correct yes sir
um were both his eyes blackened yes sir
did he have a gash over his right eye
yes sir uh were both his ears
swollen and and
cut up yes sir
did one look like it was almost
cauliflowered swollen
they did appear to have swelling yes
did you see
an injury to his side area
uh yes like an abrasion and abrasion or
numerous
abrasion abrasions bruises abrasion sir
now
when you got there
michael barissone was being
treated by a number of paramedics
correct
he was treated during the transport
okay and he was treated by
a kimberly
head and a daniel vitale correct yes sir
now
when you were there
did you hear michael barrison
at any point in time
say that he didn't recall the event that
had just taken place
no sir not specifically
i'm going to show you what has been more
d10f
and ask you to take a look at this
i'm aware of you
judge while the detectives are viewing
that can we be heard of sidebar sure
production's overwhelmed
do you recall michael barristone saying
that he didn't recall what happened
i understand that's in my notes sir but
that wasn't something that i heard him
say directly
in speaking with the officers i believe
that's where that
note came from
but not from anything i heard him say
directly
how many officers told you
that michael barrows don't hit him
that's
that's here say mister can you number
judge
it's still hearsay the witness said
he didn't hear it himself it came from
other people so
i'm just asking how many people
regarding that
well
did you hear multiple officers did you
speak to multiple officers about things
mr barroso may have said
i spoke to officers judge about what
took place at the scene how many
officers just tell me how many officers
did you speak to about what happened at
the scene from washington township at
this point uh there were three officers
there
now
you didn't put that in your report
correct
no sir
now
prior to statements that you did here
would you agree with me that michael
barrasson was in excruciating
pain
he was expressing the fact that he was
experiencing pain yes sir
and
what if anything did you observe with
regards his demeanor
with regards to being in pain
aside from the again he was verbally
expressing that he was looking for
something to
treat the pain he was experiencing when
when someone touched him or or
came near his his arm you know did he
make facial expressions did he
indicate from his expressions or his
actions that he was in
serious pain from his expressions yes
you could see that he was experiencing
pain
now
would you agree with me
that you took
detailed copious notes correct
yes sir
and
when i say detailed and copious
you make specific references with
regards to
exact times
when things
happen or you observed correct
yes
you put the exact time he arrived at the
hospital 15 20 correct
uh that was my arrival sir are you
reading from his notes or refreshing his
memory
it's like it looked like you were
reading his notes so if you if you want
to refresh his memory you can do so
you put in an exact time when michael
barrasson got there correct yes sir
exact times when other officers from
washington township arrived correct
yes
you
literally
wrote down every detail
that you observed
contemporaneous with
what you observed correct
yes sir
now
how many days did you write your
official report after the incident
my report was drafted the next day sir
when was it
when's the date of the report
are you asking the date on the actual
report the date on the actual report uh
that's the date that my supervisors
approve it not the date that i completed
sir
is there anything on the report that
indicates the date that you completed it
on the report sorry no
anywhere
is there anything to indicate
that
you did the report prior to
october 23rd
against her
date on the report is the date it was
approved by a supervisor
not the date that i completed it
or not the date that i typed it if
that's what you're asking
did you make a uh a rough draft of that
report
yes there was a draft of the report
before it's approved okay and where is
that rough draft of the report that you
made
earlier than the date that was approved
it's typed on that report through our
infoshare system
and when you say
a supervisor had to approve it
did
someone from your office go over
the report
to make sure that it was
accurate and correct
a supervisor has to approve it yes sir
and what are they approving
i can't testify as to what they're
looking at in the reports are what's the
purpose of a supervisor to their
knowledge
reviewing a report before it's submitted
to review what is contained within the
report
and has the supervisor ever
told you to take something out or
include something prior to it being
submitted as a an official report
it's a pencil
it has happened though correct
or
something is amended in the report yes
yes
now
michael barrasson
and correct me if i'm wrong
at 1356
made the first statement that we
testified to correct
that's not correct sir it's a clerical
error now when you say clerical hour
whose clerical error is it
that's my report sir
did your supervisor pick up that
clerical error and talk to you about it
i can't testify as to what
they did or didn't do sir
what time did michael barizone make this
statement that you just talked to
that would be my life in the last six
months that would have been at 15 56
hours
so
3 56
pm
so your report is inaccurate correct
that time should be 13 15 56 sir
and
when did you realize that there was a
clerical error in your report
uh after it was approved sir
and at any point in time did you
seek to address that that issue
and change the report to reflect the
accurate time
no sir
is there anything else in that report
that's inaccurate no sir
now
before the first statement
you've testified that michael barrasson
received
fentanyl correct yes sir
and he also received fentanyl academy
after that statement correct yes sir and
soon after that isn't it the fact that
soon after what you mentioned two things
fentanyl and then fentanyl and ketamine
so specify what you're talking about
please soon after the second injections
of
fentanyl in ketamine
he basically passed out correct
yes he became uh
it appeared like in a state of sleep
now
when you first saw michael barrasson was
he incoherent
i wouldn't describe this that no sir
now
you testify to a second statement
correct
yes sir
and
you testified
correctly from wrong
that at some point in time
michael barristone said
he was sorry
correct yes sir
and you put that in the official report
correct yes sir
now
can you tell me
whether or not
anywhere in the notes that you took on
the day in question
contemporary contemporaries with
what was going on
did you include in your notes anywhere
that he said
i'm sorry
after that note of that statement no sir
i'm referring to the notes that you took
at the time in the
incident
correct yes in in my notes
after that no it's not in my notes
when you say after that
i want to make sure i'm clear on this
point in your official notes
isn't it the fact
that nowhere
is there any reference
to michael barristone saying the words
i'm sorry
in my notes no it is not sir
but the other two specific statements
word for word
are included correct
yes in my notes
and in your official report correct yes
sir
now
you indicated you were standing outside
of the area where michael barrasson was
was was being treated
you don't recall the exact words of what
he said correct
correct no the statements were made in
effect they weren't made directly to me
sir
was he talking to anyone or was just
talking to himself he was speaking out
loud sir
was he
talking to anyone based on your
observations
at which point sir at any point
with respect to him making any
statements
the statements
the statements that you've testified to
was he
talking to anyone hold on a second
just for clarification maybe a little
confusion
whether he's
this witness may not know whether he was
speaking directly to someone
when he was uttering those statements
perhaps the better question is was there
anyone present around his bedside was he
being treated at that time when he spoke
just so we avoid confusion
when he made the first statement about
these people destroying his life they
were all made while he was in his uh
hospital bed
and were people around him yes or a
medical person out there sir
were they asking him questions or
was he just making these statements
without any questions
they weren't prompted by any specific
question by anyone sir
certainly
i'm going to show you a number of
photographs
eight
d 800-52
to d
800-75
and ask you just to
review these
mr valencia would you still like these
pants out or would you don't put those
back
you can put them away thanks
thanks
thank you you're welcome um i'm just
going to ask you to take a look at these
photographs
just up here don't let anyone else see
them
maybe put them face down when you're
done okay would you like me to go
through them yep
the paper clips are just copies there's
coffee
foreign
yes sir are they consistent with your
observations of
the injuries that michael barristone
suffered on that day yes sir
now
you testified that
that one statement
in your notes that
you didn't include in your report
was
something someone else told you correct
which statement specifically sir
the statement with regards to i don't
recall
yes sir
in your three pages of notes or four
pages of notes is there any other
reference
to anything that anyone else told you
during
your time
at the hospital
i'd have to review that sir can you
i mean on the first page scuffle
if it's from someone else
what someone else told you it's hearsay
but there is some reference about
something that someone else told you
just answer yes or no yes sir fine
what's the next question i'm done
judge could i have a breakout room to
show the detective his report
sure
not to publish it just to show it to him
based on yes
judge while that's pulling up for the
record this is uh s-149
for identification okay
detective while that's pulling up you
were asked some questions about times
that were in your notes in your reports
yes sir and i think you testified on
direct examination
about the approximate time that you
arrived to
morristown medical center yes sir
i'm going to direct you to
what should be coming up in front of you
as s-149 do you see that yes
is that a
copy of the report that you were
discussing earlier on cross-examination
yes sir
and if uh we look on page one
in the narrative section
does that indicate approximately what
time you arrived at
morristown medical center yeah sure what
time is that approximately 15 20 hours
and for those of the jury who are not
familiar with 24 hour time what time is
uh 15 20 in 12 hour time
3 20 pm
now scrolling down to page two of that
report you were asked questions about
the times that you overheard
the defendant make certain statements
yes sir
and does it indicate on that page
approximately halfway down when you
observed or overheard him make those
statements yes sir
what is the first time that's typed
there in your report it's typed
uh 13 56 hours which would be
approximately which would be what time
in 12 hours uh 1 56 p.m
what time was the second statement typed
in
15 57 hours which is what time 357 so is
it fair to say that you did not hear
the defendant make a statement at 1 56
that afternoon before you arrive to this
hospital that's correct sir and that's
what you're indicating with a clerical
error or a mistake in your in your
record
go for the question
oh you may step down thank you thank you
mr shalhorn yes your honor the state
will call
officer jason hensley officer jason
hensley please
yeah
hold on one sec uh miss radler is the
person from i.t here
i'm just having some computer issues i
need i.t to take a look at it
all right let's swear in the witness
while we wait
left hand on the bible thank you raise
your right hand do you swing the
presence of almighty god that the
testimony of to this court regarding
this matter shall be the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth i do
please state your name i'll spell your
last name for the record jason hensley
h-e-n-s-l-e-y
on the scene
we'll begin and then when it gets here
we'll just take a quick a quick uh
hopefully five minute break
officer hensley can you please introduce
yourself to the jury and tell them where
you were
officer jason hensley i work with
washington township police department
and approximately how long have you
worked for the washington township
police department approximately four and
a half years what's your current rank
and assignment patrol
and patrol officer
do you have any prior law enforcement
experience before joining the washington
township police department i worked for
two years in madam township police
department
direct your attention to august 7 2019
were you working for the washington
township police department at that time
yes what were you doing on the afternoon
of august 7th 2019. i was working a
third party detail can you explain to
the jury generally what that means
construction companies and outside
contractors hire us to do traffic
control in their work zones when they're
working in town
do you recall what the nature of the
third party
assignment was on that date yes we're
working with a tree trimming company
do you recall the approximate area where
that was happening
uh westmoreland
how were you dressed on that day
i was wearing our class c uniform and
what uniform
are you wearing today important this is
a class b uniform what would be the
difference between a class b uniform and
a class c uniform
there's nothing different except the
badge and nameplate are embroidered
there's the patch on each arm and that
day in question i was wearing a short
sleeve
version of that uniform
directing your attention
just hold on for one second
[Music]
um
um
go ahead mr shellhorn you're your honor
is this supposed to be here
no mr blankens can you take that back
please
thank you officer
officer hensley uh
i apologize if i already asked you this
question but i just want to make sure
that the record is clear
do you recall where you were working
that or the general area where you were
working that third party detail at
approximately 2 15 the afternoon of
august 7 2019. at that point we were on
a lunch break and we were right outside
our town line in industrial area um we
were in the parking lot at that point
were there any other washington township
police officers there with you yes who
was that detective
and i'm just going to ask you to keep
your voice up a little bit if you uh can
that microcode doesn't actually amplify
okay supports so just to make sure that
the jury in the back behind you can hear
you yes uh
do you recall how detective heimer was
dressed he was dressed in the same
fashion i was wearing a classy uniform
at that time approximately 2 15 that
afternoon do you recall receiving a
dispatch over your radio yes do you
recall the address where that dispatch
was for yes what was the address 411
west mill road what was the general
nature of the dispatch active shooter
what did you do after receiving that
dispatch
i
confirmed that with detective heimer
what the nature of the call was
and he had a ballistic vest with him at
that point so he began to respond
what did you do
i looked in my trunk and found a
ballistic vest and i responded as well
had you ever been to the property of 411
west mill road before yes can you
describe for the jury in a general sense
the layout of the property
there's a farm house several hundred
several hundred feet off of west mill
road on the left side of the driveway
going in and as you proceed back into
the
rear of the property there is a horse
equestrian facility
are you able to see the equestrian
facility from the road
maybe the roof if i recall correctly
when you
uh proceeded to 411 west mill road in
response to that dispatch at some point
did you pull into the driveway yes were
there any other police officers already
on scene detective heimer and officer
wardenberg
do you recall uh if you saw where
their vehicles were parked
they were parked in the driveway
um
the portion of the driveway that goes
all the way back to the horse farm
where were they parked in relation to
the area of the farmhouse
right next to it off if you're driving
in it'd be to the right of the farmhouse
upon pulling into the driveway and
seeing their cars there could you see
them
no
um what did you do when you saw their
cars there i put my car in park and got
out and immediately heard commotion
coming from the rear of the residence
where did you go
that's why i went to the rear of the
residence what did you first see when
you arrived in the area of the back of
the residence
i saw officer wurttenberg and detective
hymer and three unidentified parties
do you recall the position of the
unidentified parties
officer heimer was standing over
one
there was a gravel pile in that piece
that area and officer wurttenberg was
with another and there was a female that
was laying next to
the stairs where officer heimer was
standing over top of the male subject
during the course of uh the
investigation as it evolved did you come
to learn who the identities of those
people were yes did you learn who the
female was yes who is that lauren canada
did you come to learn the identity of
the person that detective hymer was
standing by yes who was that michael
barrasson do you see michael barrasson
in court today yes can you identify him
by an article of clothing that he's
wearing
he's wearing a white shirt yellow tie
received at the council's table on
identifying the defendant for the record
and you indicated that uh officer
wortenberg was with another male yes did
you come to learn who that male was yes
who is that robert goodwin
where did you go first when you saw this
to
officer heimer's position and what did
you do when you got there
i began
assessing the victim
or the patient who was on the ground at
the time what were your initial
observations of ms kenner
she was pale um and had a little bit of
blood on it
judge may i have permission to display
s389 to the jury it is
right s 389 is being displayed on the
screens the monitors to the members of
the jury go ahead mr shellhorn officer
hensley can you please tell the jury the
approximate area where you parked your
patrol car when you got into the
property
right in the area that says driveway
on the on the diagram right in that
general area
and when you proceeded to the area of
the rear of the farmhouse can you
describe the area where you saw
officer wurttenberg and mr goodwin
approximately
between the rear steps and the part
that's labeled gravel pile
do you see the area where you saw
detective hymer and uh the defendant yes
can you describe for the jury the
approximate area where you observe the
two of them
it says back door
in the bottom right corner of the
portion that says house they were right
off the
stairs there
and uh where where did you observe ms
cameron
if you're looking at it
from right there it'd be to the left of
the rear stairs between the bush and the
rear stairs
now you indicated that you first went
over to the area where detective heimer
and the defendant were and miss canara
yes
uh
and you indicated that you made some
observations of miss canorack yes what
did you do at that point i began to
remove her clothes to see where
she
the wounds were and what the nature of
them were did you identify an
approximate area on her body where there
were ones the upper left portion of her
chest did you see how many there were
uh it appeared there were two bullet
foods
and could you uh
describe what you saw as you removed
some of the clothing that was in the way
and you saw those wounds in that area
there was a little bit of blood
and what looked like to puncture or
bullet wounds
what did you do next
i began to try and hold pressure on the
two wounds
there was a lot going on there but as
from what i had that's the only thing i
could uh medically do at that point
at some point did other officers arrive
to the scene yes
several washington township officers
arrived did they bring anything with
them they brought various medical gear
what did they do when they got on scene
um i gave over
patient care to them because i wasn't a
certified emt at that point
so they had better knowledge of what
miss cantarak needed medically
versus me
after turning over care for ms canarac
to the other officers what did you do
next i
took custody of mr barrison
at the time you took custody of him was
he restrained or handcuffed in any way
he was handcuffed
were there any other officers with you
when you took custody of them no
when you took custody of him did you
tell him anything
i advised him of his miranda rights
um at some point during my interaction
with him yes can you explain to the
members of the jury what miranda rights
are miranda rights are given to anybody
who's in custody or who may or may not
be subject to an investigation
why did you give him uh or advise him of
his miranda rights at that time due to
the nature of the call
we're still sorting stuff out how did
you advise him of those rights
i carry a card on me every time i'm
working and
i read them verbatim off a card so that
they're systematic and the same every
time do you recall and i can refer you
back to s 389 do you recall the
approximate area where you were when you
advised the defendant of those rights
somewhere between the rear steps until
he was seated against an enclosed
trailer which is depicted in this
diagram
can you describe the general area where
that is
um there's a vehicle that's
marked fl
req
one f seven q ue
it was at some point in the gravel area
directly in front of that
after you advised him of those rights uh
did he acknowledge them in any way yes
he verbally acknowledged that he
understood the rights and you recall
specifically what he said in
acknowledging what you had just told him
no i don't recall i know it was a verbal
acknowledgement
did you ask him any questions after
administering those rights to him
yes just medical questions trying to
ascertain
if you had any further injuries that i
couldn't see
were you able to observe if you did have
any injuries it appeared he had a
laceration on his head
his head and face were covered in blood
now you indicated that after uh at some
point after you took custody of mr
barrissone in the area of the back door
of the residence
uh that you
were with him as he made his way across
the
driveway there yes can you describe to
the jury where he went first
i took him away from the immediate area
so
other members of the department can
render aid to mrs canorack
and which was directly in front of that
pick that truck i described before which
is about in the center of that gravel
parking lot behind the rear door
when you were in that area do you recall
was he standing or sitting or something
else
i believe he was kneeling at one point
um i know that i did
search him when he was standing though
how did you search him
so
any anytime we search we're taught in
the academy i mean it's
standardized and systematic you're
searching for any weapons or any
contraband um and that's what i did when
i searched mister
did you
pat down or
touch parts of his body yes yeah it was
a routine pat down um looking for
anything
did you find anything in any of his
pockets yes in his right front pocket of
his pants there was a handgun magazine
judge may i approach the witness yes
officer hensley i'm going to show you
what's been entered into evidence
already as s-178
look at that and determine what that is
[Applause]
yes
what is that
that's the handgun magazine i pulled
from mr barrison's right front pants
pocket
when you pulled it out of his pocket
were you able to tell whether there were
bullets in the magazine yes did you take
the bullets out at that time no what did
you do with the magazine i gave the
magazine to sergeant bigham who was also
there helping me pat down mr barizone at
that time did you see what he did with
the magazine sergeant bigham secured the
magazine in the rear of if i recall
correctly corporal fellini's the trunk
of corporal fellini's patrol vehicle and
approximately how far away was that
vehicle from where you were with mr
barrison approximately 15 to 20 feet
after locating that in mr barrison's
pocket
and turning it over to sergeant big um
or
i'm sorry i forgot what rank i think it
is sergeant sergeant and turning that
over to sergeant bigham uh did you take
the defendant michael baristone anywhere
else on the property yes he was moved
from that specific area to the side of
an enclosed trailer
which is on the edge of the gravel lot
approximately 20
feet from my location
did you see while he was in that area if
he was treated or
examined by any ems personnel he was
i'm going to show you what's been marked
as s 250 and entered into evidence
already
what is s 250 a picture of
that's mr barriston's clothing and shoes
and is that in the approximate area you
were just describing to the jury where
you saw him receiving medical treatment
yes
were you given any assignments with
respect to uh mr barrissone and his
transport off the property yes what were
you
instructed to do i was to company
i was instructed to accompany mr bear
zone to morristown medical center did
you do that yes how did he get to the
morristown medical center
i'm not sure if it was a long valley
first aid squad ambulance or an atlantic
ambulance but it wasn't he was in the
back of an ambulance were there emts or
other medical personnel in the ambulance
yes what were they doing during the
course of the the transport from
long valley to morristown assessing and
treating mr parasite
do you recall approximately how long
that transport took
approximately 30 minutes
was he
was mr barristone the defendant uh
restrained or handcuffed while he was in
the back of the ambulance yes
do you recall specifically any of the
medical conversations or the
conversations that he was having with
the medical personnel
they were just talking speaking
medically to him in the sense of asking
him to try and ascertain what was wrong
with him and uh they were treating him
medically
did you ask him any questions no
during the course of time that the
defendant was in the back of the
ambulance being transported to
morristown
uh did he make any statements that you
do recall yes were those statements made
in response to any specific questions
from the medical personnel no
can you tell the jury what you recall
over hearing the defendant say
is this real
and i need to wake up
do you recall the approximate number of
times that he made each of those
statements undetermined but there was it
was multiple several times
did you hear him say those words
verbatim or is that a a summary or just
your recollection of what you said if i
recall my report correctly that were
direct statements
his quote
were those statements recorded
no
were they required to be recorded
no
what was the defendant's appearance or
demeanor during the time that you were
observing him in the
in the ambulance appeared robotic
other than in the ambulance i was seated
behind him so i wasn't able to
see his appearance
i mean you see his face
no i saw the back of his head
did you have any issues understanding
the words he was using or the language
he was using no
do you recall when you arrived at
morristown medical center
yes
what happened when you arrived there
mr persona was taken out of the
ambulance and brought inside
the hospital and brought to a trauma
room do you recall if there were any
other members of law enforcement at the
hospital already
officer barnes followed me um
that i recall he was the only officer
that i directly remember seeing when i
got out of the ambulance
when you went inside did you see other
members of law enforcement
officer barnes
and at some point
detective gould was there from the
prosecutor's office
what was your role at the hospital once
you arrived there i was to maintain
contact with mr barristone visually in a
security function
where were you while you were doing that
i was outside the trauma room that mr
barrison was in
do you have any recollection of the
treatment that he received while he was
there no
no further questions for officer hensley
at this time thank you judge
well council course examination please
good morning officer good morning
now
you were with hamer uh when you got the
call to respond
detective heimer yes
and uh
[Applause]
he left and you immediately followed
thereafter correct negative
uh how
long after
did you arrive
uh from hama
approximately one minute after detective
hymer
all right so
detector heimer gets there you arrive at
productivity a minute after correct
approximately yes and and
you immediately have an opportunity to
observe michael barisson correct
immediately in what sensor
you were right there with cataract and
barista yes when i went to officer
heimer's position yes i immediately
observed him okay and would you describe
michael barrasson at that point
uh as partially conscious
yes
would you describe him as incoherent
i didn't have too much interaction with
him so i
when you say you didn't have interaction
with him
you mirandized him correct
at that point yes yes i did
and was he
incoherent at that point no
now
you said you used your uh card that you
always used correct yes and again that's
i assume so you don't leave anything out
you
ask the questions verbatim each and
every time correct yes
and your testimony that on day you asked
all the questions on your card correct
yes
and what was michael barristone's
response to each and every question
at the end
his he verbally acknowledged that i read
him
his miranda warnings
what do you mean he verbally
acknowledged
i don't recall if he said yes or i
understand or something of that nature
but he verbally verbally acknowledged
that he understood what i just told him
and and what did he say when
you said
having these rights in mind
talk to us now
i don't recall
you asked him that question correct yes
and
you have no recollection of of what he
said in response to that specific
question that was on your card it was a
summary of i read everything
and then i asked him if he
understood and then you asked him
having these rights in mind do you wish
to talk to us now correct
i don't recall what his answer was to
that
at that point i wasn't going to ask him
anything investigative
now
when you got there was michael barissone
handcuffed yes
was he handcuffed behind his back
correction correction
he was not handcuffed he was handcuffed
while i was there
was he handcuffed behind his back
yes um
did he make any indication to you
when his left arm was put behind his
back in handcuffs that he was in pain
not i did not handcuff him so to me no
while he
strike that while you were there
interacting with him
his hand
were cuffed behind his back correct yes
and
at any point in time
when his hands and both arms were cuffed
behind his back
did he indicate to you that he was in
pain not that i recall
did you
notice anything or observe
him which would indicate to you that he
was in pain no like wincing or
making expressions when when he was
moved one way or another no
now
you rode with them in the hospital of
strike that you rode with them in the
ambulance to the hospital correct yes
and
um
did you see any medical personnel
uh inject any
thing into his body
i did not observe that no did michael
barizone at any point in time
was he still handcuffed behind his back
if i recall correctly yes
based on your observations
before he was put in the ambulance you
made an observation and correct me if
i'm wrong that his
left arm
could well have been fractured correct
i don't recall that
um
i'm going to show you 10i which is a
copy of your police report
and if i
can quicken things up here
i'm going to refer you to
a sentence in the fourth paragraph of
your official police report
yes i remember that he
several lacerations and a possible
fractured left arm
and you were aware of that
before it was placed in the ambulance
correct it appears so
and did anyone try to
accommodate that fracture when they
secured him in the ambulance to your
knowledge
not that i'm aware
when was
your official report uh done
um i don't know if there's an author
date
if this is accurate then it was on
august 11th
when was it approved by supervisor
oh it says yes report date august 11th
now what does report date mean
if i could recall that it's when i
authored the report
not what a supervisor
approves your report correct
uh i'm unaware of that i've never
approved the report
but
this state on your report that says
report date
indicates to you that that's when you
wrote and submitted it correct
it appears that way yes
now
during the transport to the hospital
it's your testimony that
michael barrisson repeatedly said
is this real
is that correct
yes
and he said it
how many times
multiple times i can't put a number on
it right so so as he's going to the
hospital he continually says
or says multiple times is this real
is this real
he said it in conjunction in conjunction
with the other statement that had in
quotes there okay the other statement
i need to wake up
i need to wake up
how many times did he say that same
amount of time since the first statement
they were one in the same
he was saying them one after the other
the same phrase
now
you would uh
indicate it on direct that you uh you
were familiar or of this location
correct
yes
uh you would responded on august 1st to
an incident correct
yes
and will you agree with me that michael
barrasso looked
much different
on the seven than he did on the first
correct and what contact sir
his demeanor
i don't really have a
clear picture of his demeanor right now
and finally
the term that you used to describe him
was
robotic correct yes
nothing friendly
any redirect
no thank you
you may step down thank you
mr shellhorn
dude i believe i have one more witness
but i'm not sure
that he's uh
here yet so i know it's a little bit
early
for our morning break but
all right um
we'll take our morning break early
we'll take 20 minutes
who's your next witness
edward david
all right ladies and gentlemen we'll
take our morning break for 20 minutes
thank you
on the
record just wait for the door to close
please
okay i'll be seated
the detective just advised me he is on
route i think
is here somewhere we're just trying to
get him to the courtroom
how long
you